it is the 2022 awards season folks and
the 94th academy awards is approaching
quickly and with a packed 10 best
picture nominations this year the
questions are stacking up will will
smith rise as king for his first ever
oscar win for best actor can steven
spielberg dance and sing his way to
another win for best director does the
dog have the power to nab top prize or
could it perhaps be no way home the
spider-man oh wait it wasn't nominated
hello everyone my name is mark ellis and
welcome to technically the after show
but this is going to act more as a
preamble to the 2022 oscars ceremony
that's right we are here to run through
all of our picks and when i say our
picks i mean two esteemed very special
very informed guests i'm just running
the ship because i'll be honest with
everybody at home i want to go 23 for 23
on my ballot not because i need the
perfect score just because i so
desperately want to beat my mom in our
annual oscar pool now if you're like me
and you want to get as many pics right
as possible you should probably listen
to what our experts have to say and then
i'll introduce them and then i get the
power of being the tiebreaker and so way
too much for me which is why i should
introduce scott mance and jacqueline
coley jacqueline coley is an editor at
rotten tomatoes scott man someone you
see on every red carpet and every panel
hosting things from coast to coast and
now they are here they are ready to go
jacqueline i want to start with you
just as far as the oscars itself and
really awards season how is the pandemic
changed the process of how we look at
awards and how we prognosticate what we
could see when at the oscars
yeah this awards season particularly of
the oscars the two biggest things that
have affected the season is the pandemic
and then also the olympics which sort of
jumbled up the calendar which it does
every four years as far as the olympics
but with the pandemic a lot of the
precursor awards that we would have at
this point when you me and scott were
sitting down you know in the office
doing this have been removed also one of
the reasons why we're doing this at home
so we don't have the wga and the pga and
the critics choice awards we do have the
golden globes and we do have the sag
awards as sort of precursor awards to
decide what's happened but
with the baptist dga wga and a lot of
the guild awards still coming
we are a little bit better than
guesswork this time of year well sir let
me roll it to you in just one sec but
first i'm going to tell everybody at
home watching around the world how we're
going to do this ceremony this is the
only time where i get a plus due to the
event and jacqueline and scott are going
to be on my arm as we take you through
each and every category that the academy
awards in their 94th iteration has to
offer we're going to start with best
supporting and then we're going to go
through to all the way down to the best
short animation and then we're gonna go
to our big four which is your lead actor
and actress director and ultimately best
picture don't worry we did not forget
about the fan favorite which is a new
category that i put in quotes that the
oscars has initiated this year to award
some popular films some love we also did
a fan pull here at rotten tomatoes so
for every category rotten tomatoes and
their incredible social team did a poll
for fans and it says hey which do you
think is going to win and so i'll let
you all know which one that one after we
get scott and jacqueline pick and maybe
that could sway me if once again i have
to wield my tie breaking silver hammer
so with all of that out of the way make
sure those pencils are sharpened you're
ready to go because again mom
junior's coming for you i'm taking it
this year with the help of my dear
friends jacqueline and scott here we go
with your best actress in a supporting
role kicking things off with you scott
mance who is taking the best supporting
actress oscar this one is easy i think
this is one of the lock categories
supporting actress ariana dubose for
west side story i loved everything about
west side story so to say that ariana
dubose is the best thing about west side
story is a pretty bold statement but she
just stole this movie from just such
heavyweights and i just thought she was
just absolutely magnificent halfway
through the film i felt like she is
going to win supporting actress and of
course she is on her way especially
after the sag award win
all right jaclyn you and scott have a
good natured uh rivalry when it comes to
oscar picks are we starting off
copacetic or do you have a different
take
we're gonna pretty much start off cope
setting the only thing i would add to
that is jesse buckley's nomination for
the lost daughter essentially came out
of nowhere in a lot of people's
estimation which to me means that there
was a a definite i would say group of
folks that were very interested in
whether or not she could take home a
prize because she's been sort of on the
outskirts of a lot of stuff so i still
think it's ariana dubose's toulouse
however
keep an eye on the lost daughter because
i will say
this year a film based in america a very
american story i don't think is going to
be the one that wins as easily i am
going to go ariana dubose as well and
the fans however went different they
went with kirsten dunst power the dog 39
of the fans voting for kirsten dunk that
is the first but not the last time
you're going to hear the name power of
the dog in this discussion as 12
nominations can sort of get you some
love when we do shows like this so let's
move on to best supporting actor
starting with you jacqueline coley who's
taking the little guy
i think this one is definitely a
consensus pick and i think that uh scott
is going to be agreeing with me on this
one i got to spend a lot of time with
this cast and i'm going to go ahead and
put my mark on troy cotzer for coda he
also is sitting in the front runner
position as well
i couldn't agree more troy kotzer he's
you know that that movie is very very
special i've been singing its praises no
pun intended for 13 months since i saw
it for the first time at sundance as
part of the virtual film festival last
year and it has been my favorite movie
all year long i've never wavered on this
even after the fall film festivals
kicked in with all those movies it's a
special film and uh you know of course
troy kotzer won the saga war for
supporting after i think it's a lock as
well
i mean look i'm with y'all but the fans
seem to have a disagreement they seem to
love the power of the dog because cody
smith mcphee was the fan pick with 35
percent of the vote as my dog is
currently snoring on the couch so let's
move on to original screenplay scott
mans going back to you this sometimes
can be an indicator as to what could win
best picture where do you see original
screenplay going uh it's usually your
right mark it can lead to uh you know
sort of give a good sign as to what's
going to get best picture in this case
i'm not so sure because my pick for best
uh original screenplay is belfast
written by kenneth branagh i love the
movie and i saw the telluride last year
last september but i feel like it's kind
of lost a little momentum and i feel
like its best chances are for original
screenplay and that kenneth branagh will
win his first academy award
all right jacqueline you feel in the
love for ireland
i do actually i do think that belfast is
actually more of the consensus pick i
will say that it's also an international
film i think you're going to see in my
pics today
international reach and international
audience are going to be a much bigger
factor in the academy awards this year
and every year going forward because of
how many folks they've invited over the
past few years so kenneth branagh being
such a name on the international stage i
think it's going to serve him better
than any of the other folks the only one
i would put beneath that is the other
international film and that's worst
person in the world but the lack of a
best picture nomination makes me think
belfast has got it
yeah the worst person in the world 98 on
the tomato meter and it's funny because
i would take belfast as well that's why
i encourage everybody to check in your
oscar pool but the fan vote went with
don't look up which is the only rotten
movie according to the tomato meter
in this category 56 of the tomato meter
so don't look up is the fan pick but i
think i'm going with belfast one of my
favorites of the year but that's not the
only screenplay category no there's
original screenplay then there's adapted
screenplay so jaclyn we kick off with
you for this one
so this is what's really interesting
about this so when you look at adapted
screenplay there's a lot of folks that
arguably have a case for themselves
because other categories where they
won't necessarily get recognition except
for jane campion she is probably
definitely going to get recognition
elsewhere so i'm knocking her off koda
is just such a huge crowd pleaser and
honestly is a dark horse best picture
candidate but on this one i'm actually
going to go ahead and go with the more
consensus choice and give it up for coda
and i when i say consensus i mean feel
good choice the more populous choice
because i really do feel this film is
peaking right at the right time and the
person who has not really had the
biggest spotlight on her about it is the
writer director sean hater
so for me this really came down to
between coda and the lost daughter
screenplays that were written by women
and i thought maggie gyllenhaal just
knocked it out of the park with the lost
daughter her feature film directorial
debut
but i do think that coda is the one to
beat here it is a beloved film it's uh
certainly on the rise the timing is
right there's a lot of momentum
around coda i think a lot of people are
going to watch this movie now who
haven't seen it yet but they will after
it's uh two history making wins at the
sag awards but regardless i think coda
sean heater gets it here all right so we
almost had our first opportunity for me
to be the tie breaker i'm just being
honest with y'all if i got the chance to
be the tiebreaker i was going to go with
what the fan polls said from our rotten
tomatoes team they said dune 45 which is
a new high for us thus far on the show
they said dune and like y'all said denny
getting not getting a best director
nomination i think maybe this could be
the category is there a chance but right
now we move on to a category where i've
been instructed to not talk about bruno
that would be animated feature jaclyn
you get to kick us off here what's
taking the cake this one's actually very
difficult i'm not gonna lie to you
animated films it's always usually about
the pixar bent the pixar disney sort of
dominance and in this category they take
three of the five entries
what's interesting is we also have flea
which is nominated in three categories
and it's one of these questions where
this film could sweep it could get a mix
of one but i don't know i think it's a
hard time to go against a film like
encanto or mitchell versus the machine
so at this current moment
i'm gonna go ahead and go with my heart
and say mitchell versus the machines but
i'm going to hope that netflix really
circles the wagons and gets these guys
out a lot for the campaigning because i
think that's going to be the difference
in this one
so you're going with mitchell's versus
the machines forever
mitchell's versus the machines against
the canto but i'm also doing it against
my better judgment which tells me
encanto billboard box office hit they
couldn't nominate the song that
everybody loves the tick tucker kids are
watching it it's just in my head i'm
like there's so much around this movie
that keeps people talking about it
it's hard to surmount however anybody
who watches mitchell versus machines
it's sort of the same way it was with
sony with spider-verse when it was able
to beat the pixar dominance it's because
it's just a better made movie well well
spider verse was a masterpiece and it
there was no other animated feature that
looked like it it was bold and daring
that's why that movie won and my better
judgment is telling me that encanto was
going to get animate a feature yes i
mean luca is the pixar movie but luca is
not one of the better pixar movies ryan
the last dragon personally for me of the
five animated feature nominees i thought
ryan the last dragon was just
magnificent i loved it it's my favorite
of the bunch and i love mitchell's verse
of the machines but i just feel like
kanto is uh uh there's a there's a
a an international feel for that movie
and i think that does go a long way the
music is great it's a beloved film it's
dizzy it's not pixar but it is disney
and that that takes it for animated
feature i think
all right so we got
in kanto versus mitchell's versus the
machines it's a fight here it's what
we're saying for animated features so
i think that both of my panelists made
great points here i'm gonna lean towards
what the fans have said in the fan poll
they went with 48 worth of encanto and
so i'm gonna go with encanto as well
that's what i'm circling about but
jacqueline does make a great point
mitchells versus machines could be
kicking it in in that final stretch for
oscar campaigning so keep your eyes it's
probably between one of those but check
out fully as well i mean all these
movies really really well done it's
great he's amazing yeah um not to be
confused with fled which is an action
movie starring lawrence fishburne and
stephen baldwin
good motorcycle chasing that let's move
on to documentary features scott we're
going back to you what people love
documentaries these days maybe not so 20
years ago now we can't stop watching
documentaries so it's a crowded field oh
well i guess this is a crowd of field i
mean
and it's always an embarrassment of
riches i have to say a documentary
feature all five of these movies are
great but the one that really struck me
as i would say the most revealing the
most uplifting the most powerful and
certainly the most
the timely and and relevant
uh over the last two years is summer of
soul
uh from searchlight pictures i mean i i
it is i mean people have sort of like
said it's like the black woodstock but
it's it's much much much more than that
i mean i'm a big music buff as you know
i think that's kind of obvious but uh
but summer of soul was so
enlightening revealing inspiring and
powerful that's my pick for documentary
feature
exactly uh we did it in ig live i've
seen the roots in concert over 17 times
i have been pushed away by quest love's
security more than once at a south by
southwest dj show so yes my biggest
summer of seoul my only caveat would be
currently as i look at the landscape
flee a film that was nominated in three
categories might get shut out
that being said also summer of soul
is led by quest love who's the director
of it
he is also not really available for
campaigning because he has this little
day job called working at the tonight
show so that film might even though it's
the better film with the better story it
might be hamstring by the fact that flea
brings in
nicholas uh
jamie from game of thrones nicholas uh
walter kota i'm going to say his name
wrong and also riz ahmed both of them
are producers on the film and are part
of the campaigning structure
just saying that i always like to say
this good movies get nominated for
oscars good campaigns win awards so
summer of soul is my pick keep a lookout
for flea for your best documentary
feature which as the panel says will be
quest love's summer of soul the fans
thought it was going to be flea 36
saying flea no picture under 98
on the tomato meter here for best
documentary feature so we go from that
to the best international film with some
of these maybe not the last time we hear
those names scott let's kick off with
you for the best international piece all
right this this is where i think drive
my car is going to get it for
international feature uh i mean i i love
the worst person in the world i'm happy
that it got nominated here and for for
for screenplay but uh this is it this i
mean there is a lot of love for for
drive my car and and it's certainly
deserving of every nomination it's
gotten before it's gotten this this is
where it's going to win for sure
all right jaclyn you got to drop my car
yeah this is absolutely where this one's
going to win it is kind of a foregone
conclusion there's about four maybe five
categories uh this year that i'm like i
don't even need to question where i
stand on them and that's drive my car is
definitely one of them
and the fans say that as well 47
going for drive my car for best
international film so we go to
cinematography and this is always one of
those sort of question marks because
there's a lot of beautiful looking films
this year jacqueline what was the most
picturesque
the most picturesque film was not even
nominated in my personal opinion but we
will get to
we will get to all of that later in
another episode of like things
jacqueline is still mad about um but of
the assorted nominees this one i think
is going to be a history making one it's
also when i said there's some things
that sound like a lock this one is
absolutely that and that is
cinematography for power of the dog
this is another aspect where dune
nightmare alley power of the dog and
west side story could all make
legitimate cases for why they are
extraordinary feats of cinematic
achievement
but there's a current story right now
about especially female cinematographers
after the tragedy on the rust set
there's a conversation right now about
this ari wegner being only the second
female cinematographer to be nominated
for this award after rachel morrison uh
had the fee with mudbound
it's almost inevitability sometimes
there is moments where everything sort
of aligns you're going to have a hard
time coming up with a better story about
why this is now and why this is needed
than ari wegner and jane campion holding
up individual oscars for what they did
in that firm
okay well i agree with that sentiment
completely agree with that sentiment but
if you're going to compare the
cinematography of power of the dog which
is glorious and beautiful
and compare it to the cinematography of
dune
there's no question
that the better cinematography in this
case
is dune greg frazier lit the hell out of
this movie it is far and away you're
gonna compare apples to apples just on
the merits of the achievements not on
everything else that goes along with it
which does play a factor in how these
you know votes uh uh play out these
winners play out greg frazier crushed it
cinematography for dune i don't disagree
dude dude was made it is a
cinematographer's movie and it is a
crafts
like toward the force for all of the
crafts production design virtual reality
story
story in dune those votes are going to
be split i i get how great it would be
to have two women win for cinematography
and director for power of the dog but
you can't just have a movie win because
of that
i'm doing the percentages wait a minute
it's not because of that i'm saying when
you talk about what people are going to
rally behind i'm telling you i
personally believe the votes for dune
and west side story are going to be
split they're both films that speak to a
similar bent as far as cinematic
appetites
whether you prefer what stephen was able
to do with his obviously i think more of
a dramatic choice in cinematography or
the sweeping lush landscape of dune but
do not tell me when you're looking at
the power of the dog and how they were
able to light and sort of place the
montana atmosphere and make it feel uh
like it was montana even though they
were filming in new zealand there is
cinematic achievement i've been to ari
wegner's cinema cinematography
presentation where she breaks down
what they do in that film and
craftsmanship and i've been to the one
for dune
one leaves you warm and understanding
what it is and the other one is kind of
a visual effects thing and some people
don't know which to discern between the
two i'm going to try to make both you
all happy right now because the fans
side with 53 worth for dune so that's
good for scott however as the tiebreaker
here i got to go with power of the dog
sorry scott and sorry dune i think i
would have given it to you for adapted
screenplay i would have done that i'm
not quite going to go there with
cinematography but maybe it's not the
last time we have a dune versus power of
the dog argument because now we careen
into film editing so scott i'll let you
kick this one off which one is going to
take the cake for all that
behind-the-scenes work post-production
okay i'm going to go again with dune i
feel like do if dude is going to kind of
have the impact on the crafts categories
like uh mad max fury road uh you know
that that is a film that just kind of
like swept through everything i don't
think that dune is going to sweep
through everything i have some some
different choices on some of the maybe
more obvious ones that people think dune
will
will get but i feel like joe walker did
a superb job on the editing of dune i
think that's the winner here
all right jacqueline you going dune i'm
also going with dune um i do believe
that this is absolutely where it's going
to go although i disagree that dune is
going to be mad max fury road i think
it's going to be more akin to blade
runner which i think only took home two
cinematography and maybe sound or visual
effects but i think it's going to be
more akin to that than the other and i
wanted to bring up mank because
mank was the winner last year and
granted it was a an off year as far as
voting and numbers and so on and so
forth but that one was also one that was
one on the presentation of that everyone
assumed nomad land with its sprawling
incredible sort of like cinematography
that movie is mostly about
cinematography and how she was able to
frame the american west it's what chloe
zhao is known for and it's still lost
to the one that was able to show what
they took away and what they added i
really do feel as far as um the
cinematography this year if you really
dissect what's going on in power of the
dog you can actually see that
the reason why it feels simple is
because of all the work they made to
make it look so effortless but there was
a lot more in how they achieved it
all right well now we're back to all
being friends because the fans agree
dune is the pick 39
in our fan poll doing 83
on the tomato meter but it goes up to 90
on the audience score so i mean like a
lot of these films are going to be fresh
if not certified fresh if not 90 or
above but as we move on to our next
category which is costume design
jacqueline the first time that in this
show anyway we've heard names like
cruella and serrano either one of those
have a chance
yes this is what's so bad is cereal is
so great and nobody got to see it and
it's peter dinklage being absolutely
incredible but this category for the
most part is gowns beautiful gowns as it
were and so i honestly believe that it
could come down
to
which of the gowns that they like better
and i just feel cruella was such a sort
of like punk rock it also won the
costume designer awards there were
several things that were sort of snubbed
um throughout that thing but cruella is
the more i'd say consistent one however
i want to just say
dune also has a very compelling argument
for costuming
and it's jacqueline durant i believe for
that one and she has such a long and
incredible lineage with the academy
so you're going cruella though for the
pick i'm going corella for the pick okay
scott your pick uh this is a toss up
between three
three of the nominees west side story uh
dune
and cruella
and i this is one of the categories
where i think you know it might be a uh
sort of a knee-jerk reaction to lump
this in with a lot of the other crafts
categories where dude will win and say
oh well dune should also win constant
design but cruella is a movie about cost
of design okay and cruella like
jacqueline pointed out it is a punk rock
looking film it is uh it is a fully
realized movie it has a really really
unique look to it uh i loved cruella it
came out last may i think it's one of
the first movies i saw back in theaters
uh after you know
everything but uh i think uh
i'm going with cruella for tossing
because it's all right
well there we go cruella the fans went
with corel as well 40 which surprised me
because i thought maybe west side story
would just run away with this but then i
forgot about even before the film came
out cruella had that very first image
that disney released probably three
years ago looking punk rock of emma
stone
with the dog on alicia what the hell are
we in for what we could be in for is an
oscar for costume design so corella's
also nominated for this next category
makeup and hair styling but there's also
a movie called house of gucci in there
how does that not get nominated for
costumes it's house of gucci for crying
out loud scott
make the world right okay well uh makeup
and hairstyle we're talking about now
okay well uh again uh you yeah i feel
like in this case makeup and hairstyle
goes hand in hand with the cost of
design and i'm again going with cruella
here again i think that dune is
absolutely a worthy choice and i have to
say that the eyes of tammy faye linda
dowds uh was i mean she is also
absolutely worthy
the the evolution of the makeup uh and
hair styling in the eyes of tavi faye i
mean you know cruella is cruella but but
the way you see
uh jessica chastain her look evolve as
the progression of that movie goes along
and and she certainly spent uh
at some cases more than seven hours in
the makeup chair
but
oh
geez um
[Music]
i'm changing my mind i'm going with the
eyes of tammy fay
good man
yeah oh yeah i'm going with the eyes of
tiny thing because because it's just
like as i'm talking about this i i'm
realizing that again it's the evolution
the progression you see the the hair and
makeup get more and more prominent
becoming like a character onto itself on
jessica chastain and and i i yeah i'm
going with with the eyes of tammy
faveland the doubts
thanks
no i'm sorry he's completely right about
that and i was like oh let him say let
him say gucci let him say cruella so i
can school i'm not gonna say gucci
no i know well so this is the thing a
lot of people are saying gucci because
of jared leto look jared little i saw
him walk past me last night when we were
doing the sag thing and honestly he's
like a strikingly beautiful man
any videos of him talking about turning
into paolo from house of gucci is a
sales pitch unto itself because you're
staring at this uh it's like watching
marlon brando and the first godfather at
the height of his sort of sexual power
playing this aging man you're like
underneath that i know what's there and
it's gorgeous so you almost get wrapped
up in it but scott is absolutely right
it's the progression of the eyes of
tammy faye not only in her but in her
co-star andrew garfield they also did a
ton of work on him and it is that
progression is watching how her looks
change over the year from this very
innocent girl who's getting in trouble
basically for me wearing mascara in
church
to eventually you know fully tattooed
eyebrows and eyeliner towards the end of
the story and for all of that to feel
believable and for you to lose jessica
chastain in it on top of the incredible
hairstyles that tammy faye wore i do
think it's eyes of tammy faye maybe
setting up another similar run to what
judy did with renee zellweger
all right so the eyes of tammy fay the
fans went 35 percent towards cruella but
then seeing y'all wholeheartedly agree
on the eyes of tammy faye which just
brings up a great point no one can stalk
can talk scott mance into making a
decision better than scott mance even if
he has to talk himself into it live we
literally watched history repeat itself
kids so now we're going to move on to
where the hills come alive because it is
the sound of music and we're starting
with the original score jacqueline what
gets you up in the morning
well nicholas patel quite literally gets
me up in the morning because he is the
soundtrack of my riding life i can't
write with words in the background so i
always put on movie scores and he is
still to this day three years running my
top spotify playlist however
i think that i'm gonna give this one up
to uh
johnny green uh would for power of the
dog he won a lot of the precursor awards
and the subtle
dance that is done within power of the
dog is mostly done through musical cues
the score actually because so much of
what is going on in the power of the dog
is left unsaid the score is more than
anything a driver of the plot and johnny
has spoken how him and jane talked about
where those themes went and when you
knew things were safe and when you knew
that they were in danger was very much
determined by the chord structures and
the music you put underneath it so power
the dog
power the dog for jaclyn for scott mance
uh when i think of the scores that wake
me up in the morning i think at john
williams for the empire strikes back
that does it to me every time as my
favorite musical scorer of all time next
to next to the blade runner scorer and
next to close encounters those are the
three and i also like allen sylvestre
score for back to the future those are
the four those are the four oh and jerry
goldsmith his score for star trek the
motion picture so
those are the five scores that get me
going all popcorn feature big scores so
big scores that's why i'm going for
you guessed it hans simmer for dune and
the reason is really simple because when
i when i was looking at this category
i was going which score do i really
remember here and the score that i
remember is dune i remember i felt that
score and it was fitting for that movie
uh a movie that was real and and the
score just accentuated all that i could
not
i've seen power the dog four times i do
not remember anything about that score
uh regardless of you know the
conversation shackling you had with the
johnny greenwood uh i i'm just going
with my heart uh hans it's yours boss
all right and this is why we do the show
this is why you're not just looking at
the end picks for what we have which we
will have for your rottentomatoes.com
but we also have these kind of debates
so that you can wrestle that around with
what you're feeling in your head at home
jacqueline's going power the dog scott's
going dune and i'm going to stick with
dune because the fans are making me
they're at 38 for dune and so jacqueline
i'm going with hans zimmer bong bong but
scott i i the only bone i have to pick
with scott now is that yeah jerry
goldsmith the score for star trek motion
picture is great but you wanted jerry
goldsmith score to wake you up in the
morning go to the gym put on rudy you're
welcome original song
now it goes to you got matt's what's
kicking off original song and what's
winning so original song i mean again
the only song that i remember here is no
time to die from no time to die uh
so that's what i'm going with and i'm
going to keep it short no time to die
baby original song
they made it easy the name of the song
is the same was the name of the movie
jacqueline you making it simple this
time
i did i'm with you know the time to die
that's going to be the winner
what else are we going to do
exactly yeah the fans felt the same way
with a majority of them going with no
time to die i was shocked that encanto
wasn't the fan favorite because i've
just heard so much love for that
soundtrack and for the songs in there
but that is the way it goes here at
rotten tomatoes with our pre oscar
spectacular no time to die so let's go
to sound let's go to those sound because
try to watch a movie on mute and just
tell me if it's as powerful without the
sound jacqueline which one had the most
powerful sound
this one is easy this is dune without
question this one is very easy this one
is very easy the mixing of dune is
incredible when you talk about the
attack on dune that the liad hoes suffer
that alone won it for sound in in my
opinion is just such a complex endeavor
all right scott are you on the same
spice as jacqueline i'm absolutely on
the same spice uh doing for sam i mean
are you kidding
could you kidding me of course it's of
course that's one of the five that i say
is a no-brainer by the way too dude
that's a no-brainer for sure all right
well our audience thought it was a
no-brainer as well first time that we've
had a vote over 50 percent go to one
movie 54
of our fans sang dune in that poll as
well and so we move off of sound music
sound effects and we go to production
design this is one of those craft
categories we're talking about so
jacqueline which one is taking top
honors at this year's oscars this is
what's tricky so nightmare alley
actually i believe has an incredible
production design and it is riveting
however a lot of it is just them going
to really cool places and the fact that
searchlight gave guillermo a bunch of
money he could secure these incredible
locations the actual production design
that is incredible is doom i mean it is
absolutely jaw-dropping what they were
able to do to create a world that is
intangible it was created in frank
hubert's novel but
it was intangible it was in the mind of
viewers and it made it as real as you
know walking into your living room so
all about dude yes i agree
dude again absolutely for production
design and again a big reason for that
is because of how how real uh denis
villeneuve wanted to keep is how
practical he he you know that the sound
stages that they used uh going on
location uh all over the place they
could have just you know kept it simple
and green screen didn't cgi'd it but no
they kept it real and i think that's why
the movie looks as unique as it does
production design for dune all the way
51 of the fans agree above 50 is well
for dunes so the fans here really
stumping for dune to win as many oscars
as possible okay we're moving on to
visual effects although this may sound
like i'm rattling off some names that
you could hear in the fan vote because
spider-man no way home is nominated
shang-chi is nominated but are either
one of those movies going to win scott
mans for best visual effects well you
know because spider-man no way home was
not nominated for best picture
maybe
this is where spider-man no way home
will win
no uh vfx
uh you know again this is another on
that like you know sort of like mad max
fury road uh train
see what i did there
mark it was a road it was a terrain i
like it yes
you sir are my snow piercer
yeah all right uh dune the effects i
mean come on really of course
jaclyn do you feel as confident as you
got those easy for dune visual effects
i'm just laughing at the train
and mark having their love affair
honestly
hey look i would have gone with uh with
something i would have gone with no time
to die or free got no i'm kidding i
would have gone dune as did the fans 48
for this one so let's go to documentary
short subject completely turning away
from your big two and a half hour epics
like spider-man and we're going to a
short subject documentary jacqueline
what's good
on short sub documentary there's like a
ton that are that are relevant however
the queen of basketball is one that i
think folks should really pay attention
to they are talking about a forgotten
basketball player and more importantly
it is the one that is backed by the best
studio so i'm going with the queen of
basketball
you know that's the key to my heart uh
you know when it comes to the shorts uh
this is by kryptonite so uh if jaclyn
has a more informed opinion on these
shorts i'm deferring to jacqueline
by the way the fans had the queen of
basketball as well 36 percent so now we
will go to the short film live action so
unfortunately our good friend robert
with the third film time stamp not
nominated this year possibly something
else for him down the line what is
nominated and more importantly what's
going to win jacqueline yeah so we have
taken around the dress the long goodbye
on my mind and please hold what's really
interesting is the dress the long
goodbye and please hold have all been
campaigning pretty heavily i have now
seen at least those three
i'm gonna go with the dress not because
i'm just a girl but because it is
another one of these stories that tells
uh tells a story across generations and
it's really compelling and also yeah i'm
gonna go with that one the other ones
are i would say
it's the more uplifting of the choices
okay scott you going with the dress
i'm going with the dress because my
informed opinion about the the dress
just came from jacqueline coley herself
so there you go oh man then we are
really messed up on live at animated
short because this is gonna be fun
okay so the long goodbye is the way that
the fans wanted to go 42 percent worth
there so let's go to short film animated
this is always sort of a stacked
category just because you see things
open for big time movies and your heart
goes with that but then there's some
other ones that maybe folks didn't get a
chance to check out uh scott do you have
any any lean did you get to check out a
lot of short animated films this year uh
the animated shorts oh yeah absolutely
i've seen these movies five times each
so i'm gonna go with robin robin on
netflix
uh just for because i just like the name
robin and it's there twice
no that is not an informed opinion
jacqueline what do you have for animated
short i'm literally right there with you
on this one i have not watched the
animated shorts yet the reason why i had
seen the live action ones was because i
sat on a panel with them and the
documentaries is because i sat on a
panel with them i have not seen any of
the animated shorts but i do know robin
robbins with netflix and just so you
know
they do quite well on the short side
all right then i'm gonna i mean like you
you're both taking robin robin so i'm
just gonna have to be the informed one
and say that i dined at a red robin not
one week ago and had a delightful lunch
and so i'm going to go with robin robin
that is the way that it falls for best
animated short and with that we're not
done yet folks no now it's really
starting to heat up because we have four
well four and a half categories left and
we're going to start with best lead
actor best lead actor here we go
jacqueline cole you're kicking us off
who is winning who is holding up that
statue who gets to give a heartwarming
speech will smith send tweet
all right like he's been
he's been the front runner as much as
i'd like to say andrew garfield could
give him a run for his money and he
might be able to
will smith's gonna probably give us some
good speeches this year they're going to
continue to cement him and if he wins
the bathtub it's over
will smith wins for his year it's his
third nomination after ali in pursuit of
happiness pursuit of happiness came out
in 2006 ali in 2001 mr movie release
dates but all of the actors nominated
for best actor were also nominated for
the sag award and will smith won
and uh out of the last the previous 27
years the winner of the sag award went
on to win best actor at the oscars 21
out of 27 times but those stats mean
nothing it is will smith's gear he's due
and important here he also produced the
movie so it is not like he just showed
up and acted like that would have been
enough but he is a champion of this film
and he is a champion as a producer as an
and as an actor it's the performance of
his career it's a slam dunk will smith
gets best actor i am with you i think
will smith gets it so what i'm surprised
by is not that you all agree or that i
agree with you it's that the fans went
benedict cumberbatch for the power of
the dog 51
saying benedict cumberbatch is going to
win so the power of the dog doing
something special for the fans right now
not necessarily for our panelists as
much but maybe that changes with the
next few categories which now leads us
to your best lead actress scott mance
who
is gonna be on stage i felt like in my
heart in my heart
jessica chastain gave the better
performance it was showier again just
like the makeup she evolved she had the
minnesota accent she sang i mean that
last song that she sang she just built
it out was like a wow moment that was
her for your consideration moment and
out of the previous 27 years the winner
of the sag award went on to win best
actress at the oscars 19 out of 27 times
i don't think that stat makes a
difference but i do think the fact that
jessica chastain won like i felt like
great i'm happy she won she deserves to
win best actress and i'm saying she will
win best actress at the oscars
all right jacqueline that's a could be
interpreted as a spicy take now you know
me pretty well you know i love my
college basketball and when i look at
this like a march madness bracket this
is the region where anybody could come
out and make the final four right
yeah maybe this is the one where anyone
could come out he's uh scott has already
already made like the best argument ever
for any surprises that could happen in
my mind this has always been between
olivia coleman and jessica chastain and
penelope cruz once the nominations came
out i didn't think nicole kidman was
really the front runner because so many
people i think are not as in love with
that performance but i'm gonna go with
jessica chastain i do feel she's in time
for a judy run because she can
definitely talk about
renee towards the end of her run with
judy was able to talk about where judy
garland was and what we did to her and
jessica will be able to do the same kind
of story when she goes into the second
half of campaigning also she has a
secondary nomination with makeup and
hair styling and with zerodark30 and the
help she can have the it's time yes
a greek person can't have that penelope
can't have that olivia can't have that
and nicole can't have it three of them
already have the oscar and the other one
just got here i also want to throw in
for jessica chastain
like will smith she produced the eyes of
tammy faye she championed she worked on
this film for almost 10 years to get
this going and here we are and we
already said we already you know jack
and i already went with uh linda dowds
for for hair and makeup for the eyes of
tammy faye and i mean the performance
and the makeup they really really do
complement each other jessica chastain
really you know i mean i'm surprised
people haven't said this before but
jacqueline is right it's time for
jessica chastain to win her first
academy award for lead actress
okay that surprised me a little bit i
don't think y'all would be uh as as an
agreement i thought there might be some
horns walking here but you're both
taking jessica chastain whereas the fans
39
say kristen stewart for spencer so
surprise surprise
hey could be anybody coming out of that
and olivia coleman always a fret don't
believe me just ask glenn close so we'll
move to directing this is the pen
ultimate award at least for us here and
usually that's the way it goes in the
oscars show who is going to win the
oscar for best directing jacqueline
coley before champion that's one of my
five that is a lock jane campion um has
now made the incredible feat of being
the second woman to ever be nominated
for best director a feat that no other
woman had achieved before she
has been long do a
director prize considering she directed
a best picture winner so jane campion 57
of the fans agree with jacqueline but
does scott mance
well
i don't know i mean
spielberg i mean you know kenneth
branagh
paul thomas anderson you got a rasuki
hama gucci for driving my car could he
pull up director bong joo no
i don't of course it's j camping are you
kidding me of course it's gene champion
j champion will be the third woman to
win the best director and it'll be the
second year in a row that a woman wins
best director after chloe's job won last
year ford nomad land if there is a lock
in anything in addition to like uh you
know best actor uh uh this is it uh jane
campion
is is aziloth best director for sure for
power the dog and channing tatum could
not be happier
yes i did another training joke
you you might get some runoff box office
for i'm just telling you if that's the
way the world works you show up you say
give me one for the dog movie you go on
fandango you hit the button for the dog
movie you just don't know what you're
getting but you're getting a pretty good
movie either way but maybe not the best
picture that's the category we've
arrived at oh no wait i'm being told in
my ear there's a special sort of kind of
24th category that at least fans can
vote online on twitter you can cast your
fan favorite vote which will be
announced at the oscars and this is
whatever movie you want whatever your
favorite film of the year was and so
naturally some folks are looking at this
as the popular movie award for the best
popcorn flick the best best audience
appeal movie could be spider-man no way
home maybe it could be something else so
let me get y'all's thoughts on the fan
favorite jaclyn scott which movie is
going to be in the hearts of fans at the
oscars oh jaclyn um well i'll just put
it to you this way it's a twitter and a
internet vote so the idiot the internet
can decide to do bodhi mcboatface or
they can give us greatness and i'm
afraid we might go the body make both
base what i mean by saying that is
people are going to rally behind a
choice which may not be the consensus
choice but it makes a statement about
what they feel about this and currently
i believe it is zack snyder's army of
the dead
is a part of that yes zack snyder's army
of the dead is a part of that campaign
because people feel that zack snyder's
justice league should have been
available for consideration it obviously
wasn't because that was a strictly tv
play that was marketed as a television
show basically so i'm actually gonna go
ahead and go with the easiest choice
which is spiderman no way home however
let me just say chaos could rain
scott man you're an agent of chaos
chaos and i go hand in hand okay
i mean come on of course it's going to
be spider-man no way home spider-man no
way home should have been nominated for
best picture not just because it made
more than like 500 trillion dollars
across the galaxy but because it is a
really really great movie and the last
hour of spider-man no way home is as
good as any movie
any superhero movie is going to get the
last hour of that film when andrew garr
spoiler alert for spider-man no way home
andrew garfield showed up and then toby
mcguire showed up my spider heart was
beating so so very hard i just lo i love
that movie it deserves to be nominated
for best picture and that is why it is
the obvious and the right choice for the
fan favorite then
if it doesn't go to spider-man no way
home i will be absolutely surprised
all right well it's got to be a movie
that came out last year and so yeah i
hope that my cries for godzilla versus
kong don't fall on deaf ears it was nice
very convenient that we had a multiverse
that could allow all these spider people
to come back but uh spiderman no way
home is probably the smart pick so i
would go with that if you're including
that in your oscar pool so have fun with
that when you're at home you're you're
hanging out with your friends you're
circling which one you think is going to
win you're probably watching this vid
maybe make that the tiebreaker
incorporate that in somehow it's just
going to up the fun quotient so now we
do go to the best picture of the year 10
very strong nominations this year
scott mance what is taking home the
prize at the oscars here's the thing
this is a really tough category to
choose
i am going with the film that i have
been championing for 13 straight months
i have never wavered in my love for this
movie even after i was taken by so many
of these other films that screened
between telly ride in september and the
december with the you know west side
story
but i love the hell out of coda for me
coda is the la la land
of 2021.
adore this movie i've seen it many many
times i love it every time it brings me
the feels every time it is a movie that
we need after these last couple of years
a a feel-good crowd pleaser that that
that just brings people to tears i'm
team coda and i'm saying koda for the
win for best picture and jacqueline he
said it was his law land which i'll
remind everybody did win best picture
for about 15 20 seconds
jacqueline now it's up to you what is
going to win best picture do you agree
with our esteemed colleague scott matt
at movie match with coda or are you
taking a different route uh going a
different route and the reason why i'm
going a different route is because again
i know people watching this video gonna
be like oh my gosh she's so leaning on
story lines and what's this and what's
that
guys it's because i've seen it do it so
many times i've seen movies that are
arguably on their face better movies
hands down better performances hands
down and a story
was able to capture the attention of
voters because this is not about what
the best film is this is about who you
can convince is the best film and i
think the film they're going to rally
around especially in our current times i
don't want to make light of what is
going on but the film that can
absolutely be something that folks rally
around when you look at the events
happening in ukraine and in europe and
say look these were people that had to
say to themselves the story of belfast
is about kenneth branagh's family that
we're literally in the middle of a war
zone when you talk about ireland during
the troubles and they made the decision
to leave who makes the decision to stay
and it is literally katrina balf and
jamie dornan having that fight
inside their family that plays out on
screen and there is tons of genuinely
heartbreaking moments all right so scott
is team coda going with his heart
admittedly jack when you're going with
belfast which might be going with your
heart too it's interesting to hear y'all
talk about those two like they are front
runners although i think a lot of people
at least maybe in the months leading up
to this thought it was going to be the
power of the dog that's certainly the
way the fans voted with 42 and so as the
tiebreaker i could go power the dog i
could go dune right now i could go don't
look up if i wanted to
but i'm gonna go with my heart and
i see scott mans going with his heart
for code i see jaclyn going for belfast
thinking about world events and i think
about the movie that i saw in a theater
for the first time in months and was
blown away by and that was
belfast i am going with belfast scott
you said you wouldn't be disappointed at
belfast one i'm down with that i'm going
with belfast but i think a lot can
change in the time we're recording this
not too far from the actual oscars and
so a lot can change leading up to it but
that's the way that we go as far as this
panel here on the after pre-oscar show
here at rotten tomatoes i have merely
been mark ellis i want to thank my
esteemed panel scott mance you can find
him at movie mance doing all sorts of
great things in front of and behind the
scenes in the world of covering film and
jacqueline coley not only she an editor
around tomatoes not only does she light
up a red carpet you can also catch her
as the i'm really just her co-host kids
i'm the chewbacca to her han solo on
rotten tomatoes is wrong you can get
that wherever you enjoy podcast and you
can follow her at that jaclyn for the
entire team here at rotten tomatoes
thanks for watching and enjoy the oscars
it's fun good luck in your pool and mom
i'm putting 10 bucks and it's a
confident 10 bucks on it this year just
you wait
[Music]
so
[Music]
you